[Musique]
bonjour marcel gaucher bonjour et merci
beaucoup de nous accorder cet entretien
alors le philosophe et l'historien ne
vous êtes nous invite à une forme d'
épreuve de vérité face à cette crise
sanitaire à regarder en face ce qui nous
est arrivé et vous avez cette phrase
choc dans un entretien au monde vous dit
la france ne joue plus dans la cour des
grands c'est terrible comment on en est
arrivé là
comment on a pu au fond être aveuglé
s'est longtemps sur l'état réel de notre
puissance et la faillite de notre état
il faut ce
bien être conscient du fait que en
france sentiment de déclassement vient
de loin parce que évidemment aujourd'hui
ça paraît ridicule même te le dire la
france a été la première puissance du
monde elle a été lui 14 yens la
prépondérance française comme disent les
historiens est là et depuis elle a
décliné avec des moments de
restauration de rétablissement qui lui
ont gardé un rang très honorable après
tout la france est une des cinq membres
permanents du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu qui est une espèce de sanctions
internationales de cet héritage mais le
monde a marché et il s'est passé quelque
chose de tout à fait déterminant qui a
été pour les français un tournant
décisif de leur histoire qu'elle entrait
dans la mondialisation
et c'est là je crois que les choses se
sont profondément déréglé on a voulu
les gouvernants successifs ont mal
appréhendé la mondialisation et l'ont
perçu à la fois dans une fois un peu
aveugle sur les vertus du marché mondial
bah oui pourquoi se préoccuper de
stocker des masques quand demain on peut
en acheter si elle a besoin
l'angine où on les aura pour beaucoup
moins cher que si on les fabrique est
ici dont une confiance excessive dans
sécu ce qu'est la mondialisation comme
si la mondialisation n'était peuplée que
de gens qui comme nous renonce à un
raisonnement stratégique et à une
anticipation des conséquences de leurs
actes et puis il ya eu d'autre part une
surestimation
une erreur de jugement
c'est l'idée que avec la mondialisation
nous étions passés dans une société de
services que ça n'avait plus de sens
pour les français de continuer à
développer une société industrielle
puisque l'avenir c'était les services
d'où cette désindustrialisation massive
l'erreur de jugement initial est
décisive même si par exemple l'euro a
accéléré le phénomène par la suite
l'erreur de jugement ça a été de ne pas
voir réellement ce que pouvait être la
position économique d'un pays et
économique entraînant le politique dans
ce processus mondial donc pour vous ce
déclassement il est au fond le fruit
d'un long processus et pas simplement
le gouvernant coupable de la gestion
très conjoncturel de cette crise non en
général les gouvernants n'ont de cesse
des criminels leurs prédécesseurs et
pour une fois que c'était vrai le
parfait
c'est très curieux tout ça c'est des
choix qui reviennent de très loin et qui
témoigne d'une espèce de consensus
élitaire français qui n'empêche pas les
partage l'opinion bien sûr qu'il ya des
élites de droite des élites de gauche
mais au-delà de ça la technocratie
public aidant il y avait une large
convergence dans le diagnostic qu'est ce
que vous répondez à ceux qui disent mais
arrêtons de nous battre notre coulpe
après tout regardons les chiffres
l'allemagne elle aussi a eu des
difficultés elle aussi s'est confronté à
la pénurie de masques est ce que on n'en
fait pas trop dans une forme de
dévalorisation on appelait mon jugement
n'a rien à voir avec une dévalorisation
c'est une appréciation réaliste
c'est du débriefing comme on dit je
regarde tout à fait rien et oui il nous
avons fait une expérience qui est un
test nous mesurons nos failles mais
c'est pas pour eux vivre dans la
pénitence jusqu'à la fin de nos jours
c'est pour réagir c'est pour rebâtir
quelque chose de différent sur la base
de ce diagnostic c'est la fonction
diagnostic qui depuis des années et des
années n'ont qu'à ce pays qui est
largement la source de la crise
politique diffuse qui le hantent
pourquoi les français sont pas révoltés
ils ont été civique disciplinés il
aurait pu dire c'est insupportable cette
pénurie de masques et descendre dans la
rue et de faire davantage entendre
comment vous l'expliquez
via un croisement de facteurs qui ont
joué le premier d'entre eux qu'on ne
peut pas sous-estimer et la peur qu'a
inspiré cette épidémie est une peur
renforcée par le sentiment qu'on ne
pouvait pas trop compter sur la
protection publique
nous aurions eu un état fort efficace
qui aurait su tout de suite prendre des
mesures l'un discipline collective
aurait été beaucoup plus grande mais
quand on a vu que nous étions tous nus
en quelque sorte tout le monde s'est dit
pas de coupable hague soyons sérieux et
par ailleurs contrairement à une image
répandue les français sont
protestataires en politique ça oui c'est
un peuple très politisée et qui ne se
laisse pas marcher sur les pieds
facilement mais
c'est une fonction attaché à une idée
très exigeant de la citoyenneté qu'on a
vu fonctionner c'est par ailleurs un
peuple prompt à la protestation mais
très civiquement discipline et quand
l'occasion s'en fait sentir et toutes
les crises historiques dans ce pays
l'ont montré c'est pas une originalité
ça vient de très loin là aussi alors
qu'est ce que vous attendez au fond de
ce grand diagnostic qui va commencer il
y aura les commission denquête vous
parlez d'une épreuve de vérité on a pu
lire dans certains commentaires qu'il
fallait réécrire une nouvelle forme d'
étrange défaite à l'ats marc bloch alors
évidemment comparaison n'est pas raison
on n'est pas en 1980 pour nous mais
qu'est-ce qu'il faut dire de ce qui
s'est mal passé pour pouvoir redémarrer
si si on peut dire il ya un enjeu très
important dans ce travail
d'investigation
il va être mené par les parlementaires
c'est normal c'est leur fonction et
j'espère je crois beaucoup que ce peut
être l'occasion d'une véritable
réhabilitation de la fonction
parlementaire dans ce pays si les
parlementaires des deux bords et des
deux chambres font leur travail je pense
que ça peut être quelque chose
kirk crédibilise profondément cette
fonction essentielle qu'est la fonction
de diagnostic d'une situation qui manque
terriblement dans ce pays on a un
pouvoir exécutif
hypertrophié qui fait sa politique ne
justifie pas c'est une femme de grand
audit de la france oui je pense que nous
avons cette occasion je pense d'ailleurs
y aura toutes sortes de contributions y
compris d'acteurs de l'intérieur de
l'état parce qu' énormément de
fonctionnaires on en a déjà eu des échos
ap partout même s'ils sont contraints à
la réserve beaucoup de fonctionnaires
ont vécu avec désolation les ordres
qu'ils renouvellent leur paraissait pas
à correspondre à la situation qu'ils
auraient souhaité ça va les entendre
c'est un fonctionnaire d'ailleurs font
l'objet de poursuites au hertha ministre
aussi l'état au sens large qu'est ce que
vous pensez de ces recours judiciaires
je pense que sont une catastrophe on les
comprend les français n' ayant
l'impression qu'ils n'ont plus de prise
sur les pouvoirs
par la voie politique on les change mais
c'est la même chose pour reprendre la
formule
qui résume la situation
s'il n'y a plus de recours par la
politique il reste le recours judiciaire
on peut incriminer telle personne pour
tels actes précis mais c'est
complètement sortir de lait pur normale
d'un fonctionnement démocratique qui
implique la distinction de la
responsabilité pénale un psy des gens
des gouvernants contreviennent aux lois
pic dans la caisse pour
ils sont poursuivis pénalement c'est une
autre question mais quand il s'agit de
conduire une politique la responsabilité
doit être politique ça ne mènera nulle
part du nom n'aura pas la réponse à vos
questions par cette voie et d'autre part
ça va des voire à le sens qu'il y aurait
à sanctionner un gouvernement si on
estime qu'il a man ag qui s'est mal
comportée face aux exigences qui est
elle aussi sanctionné dans les urnes
dans les vrais hommes c'est la voie
normale de la démocratie justement
parlons de la démocratie elle était déjà
mal en point cette démocratie française
elle était faible il y avait beaucoup de
défiance avant la crise un mystère on a
l'impression qu'elle est encore plus
faible après pour quelle raison est ce
que c'est parce que l'état de droit
était un peu suspendue dans cet état
d'urgence sanitaire est-ce que c'est
justement parce que ce sentiment d'un
état qui a failli est insupportable aux
français c'est un mélange de beaucoup de
facteurs de nouveau et il faudrait se
garder d'en privilégier pour écraser
tous les autres mais là
le vrai mal
politique français me semble situé dans
l'absence de confiance entre gouvernants
et gouvernés
oui et cela avec pour résultat de nous
faire vivre dans une confusion complète
ou une faute d'un diagnostic qui
permettrait de définir des politiques
claires qui seront toujours des
politiques divergentes il s'agite si
elle joue à laquelle je ne crois pas
c'est à l'unité nationale parce que la
divergence est de règle dans le monde
démocratique mais on peut
diverger sur les solutions divergent
rappelons sur les solutions mais on peut
s'accorder sur une problème auquel il
s'agit de répondre et c'est ça qui
manque dans la situation politique
française d'où la confusion et la
méfiance qui s'installe normalement les
gouvernances ont peur la société on l'a
vu à l'oeil nu et d'autre part les
gouvernés n'ont pas confiance dans leurs
gouvernants par principe s'ils nous
disent quelque chose il ya sûrement au
tour derrière comment on sort de cette
défiance est ce qu'il faut changer les
institutions
c'est une des voir mais c'est secondaire
je pense que le coeur du problème c'est
le bon diagnostic sur les problèmes de
la société française parce que encore
une fois ce que les gens demandent
d'abord aux gouvernants c'est de savoir
où on en est où sont les questions après
on sait qu'il est très difficile de
répondre à ces problèmes dans tous les
cas et et on s'est surtout qu'on va pas
y répondre dans les six mois par un
programme tonitruant qui résoudrait
miraculeusement toutes les questions non
mais on peut savoir où sont les
questions et dans quelle direction on
est un peu contraints d'aller par la
nécessité des choses et c'est ça qui
nous manque du coup ça donne aux
gouvernance une image détestable
d'arbitraire ce comme si c'était leur
opinion personnelle qui tout d'un coup
parce que par une espèce de loterie
électorale qui se retrouve en position
de pouvoir il décide de faire ceci cela
bhl ma réforme d'ailleurs toutes ces
réformes avec un nom propre mais pour
moi c'est l'horreur parce que une
réforme si elle est bonne elle n'a pas
de nom avec les réformes du pays la
réforme de de la collectivité france qui
se retrouvent de temps tout en la
contestant et c'est ça que nous
n'arrivons plus à faire alors c'est ma
dernière question les mots qui sont dans
le débat et emmanuel macron a esquissé
un chemin en l'indépendance la
souveraineté stratégiques notamment la
décentralisation
ça ce sont des réformes qui ne suffiront
pas à créer un sursaut ou au contraire
ça donne des raisons d'espérer ce ne
sont pas des mots qui répondent à des
problèmes
décentralisation mais nous avons
théoriquement une décentralisation est
paraît-il poussé on a vu que dans
l'épreuve son fonctionnement laissé
beaucoup à désirer pour que le mot
redonne une impulsion il faudrait donner
une critique de ce qu'a été la
décentralisation jusque jusqu'ici dans
ce pays pour voir où il faudrait aller
plutôt que ce qu'on a fait idem
indépendance mais alors
un citoyen entend ce mot dans la bouche
du président nous ne sommes plus
indépendant
s'il faut reconquérir notre indépendance
c'est que nous n'avons perdu comment
pourquoi c'est une question
même chose pour la souveraineté donc je
pense que ce sont des mots incantatoire
qui ont des vertus qui répondait y aura
des valeurs fondamentales le que ce soit
la proximité du pouvoir avec le terrain
pour la décentralisation ou la
souveraineté collective qu'est la
formule de le démocratique mais qu'il ne
voyait remettre on peine nous et connaît
maintenant cette épreuve de vérité va
diagnostiquer pour que ces mots prennent
leur sens il faut l'épreuve de vérité
auparavant donc c'est ça qui manque dans
notre cheminement politique merci
beaucoup marcel gauchet d'abord il a dû
à nos questions
[Musique]